para estudiar el crecimiento de una
bacteria un científico mide el área en
milímetros cuadrados que ocupa la
población muestra el crecimiento de la
población se puede modelar por efe dt es
igual a 24 por el elevado a la 0.4 por
de donde t es el número de horas a
partir del inicio del experimento se
muestra la gráfica de f
podemos suponer que si ft es igual a 24
x elevado a la 0.4 teme la salida de
esta función será el número de
milímetros después de t horas observa en
la gráfica podemos ver que mientras el
tiempo avanza 2 milímetros cuadrados de
la pequeña población de bacterias se
mantiene aumentando y claramente crece
es decir es la gráfica de una
exponencial creciente de hecho sabemos
que es una exponencial creciente porque
tenemos una función exponencial y nos
preguntan en qué tiempo la población
ocupa por primera vez un área de 400
milímetros cuadrados redondea tu
respuesta al entero más cercano así que
pausa el vídeo e intenta encontrar la
respuesta
esta es una captura de pantalla de un
ejercicio en khan academy nos piden que
en qué tiempo la población ocupa por
primera vez un área de 400 milímetros
cuadrados
veamos 400 milímetros cuadrados están
por aquí por lo que parece que después
de 7 horas tenemos 400 milímetros
cuadrados o más así que ponle después de
7 horas
muy bien ahora hagamos los siguientes
ejemplos basados en esto mismo ahora nos
dicen algo semejante utilizan milímetros
cuadrados para estudiar el crecimiento
esta es la función pero agregaron esta
recta y la gráfica de la recta es igual
a 600 tenemos la gráfica de efe y la
gráfica de la recta igual a 600 y nos
preguntan qué afirmaciones representan
el significado del punto de intersección
de ambas gráficas elige todas las que
apliquen bueno pausa el vídeo e intenta
responderla bien el inciso a dice
describe en qué tiempo la población
ocupa 600 milímetros cuadrados y nos
preguntan qué afirmaciones representan
el significado del punto de intersección
de ambas gráficas es decir nos preguntan
por este punto de intersección
será que este punto describe en qué
tiempo la población
ocupa 600 milímetros cuadrados bueno en
efecto ese es el tiempo donde la
población alcanza los 600 milímetros
cuadrados porque esta es la recta que
igual a 600 milímetros cuadrados así que
me agrada esta opción siguiente inciso
representa la solución a la ecuación 24
por el elevado a la 0.4 te es igual a
600 bueno si lo piensas en azul tenemos
la función y es igual a 24 x elevado a
la 0.4 t y esta es la recta de igual a
600 por lo tanto obtenemos el mismo
valor que para el valor t donde estas
dos gráficas se intersectan o dicho de
otra manera significa que esto es igual
a esto o que en efecto 24 por el elevado
de 0.4 tm es igual a 600
así que también me gusta esta opción
obtenemos un valor t donde esto es
cierto ese valor t es la solución a esta
ecuación inciso se describe la situación
donde el área que la población ocupa es
igual al número de horas no en
definitiva no es el caso porque el área
es de 600 milímetros y las horas parecen
ser un poco más que 8 así que en
definitiva no son iguales inciso d
describe el área que la población ocupa
después de 600 horas no no tenemos ni
siquiera que ver las horas ya que en el
eje t ni siquiera tenemos una marca para
600 horas así que tampoco seleccionaré
esta opción como correcta
bien sigamos desarrollando la siguiente
parte de este ejercicio y nos dice para
estudiar el crecimiento de una bacteria
un científico mide el área en milímetros
cuadrados que ocupa la población muestra
y ahora tenemos dos poblaciones observa
el crecimiento de la población y se
puede modelar por y tenemos esta función
de aquí y el crecimiento de la población
ve se puede modelar por y tenemos esta
nueva función head donde te es el número
de horas a partir del inicio del
experimento se muestra en las gráficas
de f y g
la población a se puede modelar por la
gráfica que ya trabajamos pero ahora
introducen una nueva población que se
puede modelar por gd te observa tenemos
dos funciones que crecen de manera
exponencial pero a tasas distintas y
después nos preguntan en qué tiempo las
poblaciones ocupan la misma área
redondea tu respuesta al entero más
cercano si quieres puedes pausar el
vídeo y piensa la solución
puedes ver claramente que se intersectan
en este punto ese será el punto donde
ocupan la misma área parece que es
alrededor de 175 milímetros cuadrados
pero no nos preguntan por el área nos
preguntan en qué tiempo ocupan la misma
área y parece que es ligeramente después
de las 5 horas así que si nos piden
redondear al entero más cercano pondré 5
horas
vamos a trabajar con la última parte es
el mismo problema pero nos preguntan
algo distinto que afirmaciones
representan el significado del punto de
intersección de ambas gráficas elige
todas las que apliquen bueno pausa el
vídeo e intenta encontrar las
afirmaciones correctas
bien el inciso a dice representa que
ambas poblaciones ocupan alrededor de
180 milímetros cuadrados al mismo tiempo
así que veamos parece cierto ya que hace
rato estimamos alrededor de 175
milímetros cuadrados así que es cercano
a 180 milímetros cuadrados y esto pasa
aproximadamente a la quinta hora así que
parece que ocupan la misma área en un
mismo tiempo
por lo tanto seleccionaré este inciso me
gusta esta opción
inciso p representa que en un inicio de
la población
era mayor que la población ve bueno el
punto de intersección no nos dice qué
población era mayor en un inicio
podríamos intentar dar esa respuesta a
albert ente igual a 0 cuál de las
poblaciones es mayor
puedes ver que cuando te es igual a 0 la
población a que es la curva en azul la
función f
parece mayor que la población b pero no
es lo que representa el punto de
intersección así que no no es una
afirmación cierta inciso se representa
la solución a la ecuación 24 x elevado a
la 0.4 tm es igual a 9 x elevado a 0.6 t
ya hemos hablado de esto en el otro
ejemplo donde sólo tendríamos una
función exponencial y de hecho es cierto
ya que si decidimos que la curva de la
población
es igual a 24 por el elevado al 0.4 te
decimos que la curva de la población ve
es igual a 9 por el elevado de 0.6 t
entonces el punto donde ambas curvas se
intersectan es el punto donde para un
valor de t dado obtienes el mismo valor
bien así que estas dos expresiones son
iguales es decir esta expresión te dará
el mismo valor que la otra expresión
otra forma de decirlo es que para ese
valor de t dado esta expresión es igual
a esta así que en efecto representa la
solución a esta ecuación
y el último inciso nos dice representa
la solución a la ecuación 24 por el
elevado al 0.4 t es igual a 0 no si
queremos saber cuando esta función es
igual a cero tendremos que fijarnos en
la función de igual a cero que trazará
en un color distinto y que se encuentra
aquí y después fijarnos en la
intersección de esa curva con la función
f pero no eso no es lo que representa
nuestro punto de intersección así que
tampoco seleccionaremos como respuesta
correcta este inciso